[Music]
welcome to quad Riga rarely has a piece
of EU legislation provoked protests and
pressure as intense as those surrounding
a new directive on copyright protection
in the internet will it take the Wild
West world of digital copyright
infringement or drive a nail in the
coffin of free expression on the web a
majority of EU parliamentarians took the
former view and voted yes to require
tech Titans like Google YouTube and
Facebook to scan uploaded content for
copyright violations and compensate
content providers for using their work
could the scanning process wind up
blocking not only copyright infringement
but creativity and open exchange that
prospect drove hundreds of thousands of
European Internet users to the streets
in protest copyright cashing in on the
Internet that's our topic here our
guests grace dovish is a Berlin based
freelance author who often writes about
tech and she says it is a perilous time
for content creators but Europe can't
police the entire Internet Alain Posner
is an author and commentator for the
daily newspaper de veg
he says Europe is forcing the internet
Giants to respect intellectual property
and pay for it and that's good news for
everyone except Google and Co
and it's pleasure to welcome John
Weitzman to the show he heads the
department of law and policy at
Wikimedia and he says for free and open
knowledge we need free and open exchange
on the web this reform could cause great
damage so let me start with you John
Weitzman and let's begin with the
absolute basics what is an upload filter
and why does it strike terror into the
heart of the content creator community
and upload filter is a system that is at
the server of that's installed on the
server of a platform provider and it
scans the uploads and compares that to a
database and if it finds protected work
that it is supposed to block then it's
stopping the upload or it's putting the
upload before a person to check whether
there was a license for this work and so
that's the basic technology and why are
people so worried about upload filters
in the wake of this new directive well
because the technology is very powerful
and if you have those kinds of systems
everywhere on the internet they can for
one they can be abused to block stuff
that is not just a copyright
infringement but for other reasons maybe
a government doesn't like it and claims
copyright and by that filtering stops
the publication and in general it can it
can hinder the the exchange of
information on the net and that is what
the net is about then the net is about
exchanging things
exchanging views exchanging also
opinions and and nowadays when people
use graphics or music and and visual
content to express themselves much more
than in the past and the past was mostly
text people were texting but now the web
is becoming or the Internet is becoming
a much more visual place which which
makes the power of those blocking
systems even greater and and and the
perils that people attribute to them so
Ellen helped me out a little bit here
because as I understand it the law
doesn't explicitly
we require that platforms use an upload
filter so how great is this risk that
such filters will now be put into place
and we'll essentially screen out not
only a copyright infringement but lots
of other useful material as well well
the law doesn't exclude the use of
copyright of upload filters which is
what people are protesting against
because it's totally impossible for a
platform like shall we say a YouTube
where people upload millions of videos
and so every day to screen it
individually per person so you have to
have an algorithm working to check that
as John just said so the only way at the
moment if you don't want to employ
hundreds of thousands of people and
destroy your your-your-your your
business model is to use an algorithm
and you know I think basically these
algorithms are benign most copyright
holders have registered with someone who
represents them that for instance in
Germany it's it's the G EMA kima which
represents musicians they already have
contracts with with with YouTube for
instance so YouTube or and YouTube pays
a certain amount of their profits to
these copyright holders already so the
question is could these upload filters
be a misused B could they make mistakes
and the answer to both is yes they could
but you have to ask yourself what would
be your turn see if the alternative is
that people who produce music who
produce text who produce videos who are
content providers are simply being
ripped off on a minute per minute basis
and the prophets all accrue to huge tech
giants as we've as we've heard so the
question is do we want to give copyright
holders content providers a share of the
cake the answer is yes is this the best
way to do it the answer is yes are there
problems the answer is yes so grace
dobisch you said in your opening
statement that this is a perilous time
for content creators now I know that you
have written a guide for crafters and
you have also co-founded a craft show in
the
past so tell us if someone is genuinely
creating original material wouldn't he
or she welcome stronger copyright
protection why do you say it's a
perilous time well it's a perilous time
that no one has quite yet figured out
how to make money from being a content
creator in the new digital economy
musicians are getting pennies per
thousands of plays from streaming
services the the idea that everyone who
is a content creator is registering
their work with a copyright agency it's
completely untrue anyone who is posting
images on Instagram that they've taken
is creating copyrightable works but is
not registering those with a Copyright
Office by any means same goes for a
person who sings the songs that they
made up on YouTube and they own that
copyright but they're they're certainly
not going to be filing paperwork for
every time they post a short video no
one has yet figured out how to make a
content creation really profitable on
the internet let at least of all the
newspapers who are also tightly involved
in this copyright battle so Ellen what
I'm hearing there from from grace is
that essentially the payments that could
now be collected will never reach
up-and-coming young artists who don't
have affiliations with established
publishers or established agencies isn't
there some truth to that it if they
don't have if these young or old content
I said up-and-coming okay
up-and-coming content producers don't
have some kind of organization behind
them yes they're gonna get ripped off
ever since I've was twenty I've been a
member of the German organization called
for jihad which which which protects my
copyright issues as an author and I get
paid for that
so I don't and I at that time I wasn't I
was only earning pennies and I got
fractions of pennies but I did it
because I felt that's what you do I
don't see why you can't if you want to
earn money on your stuff that you upload
then why don't you join isn't a question
of paperwork you can do it online it's
three clicks no literally like that for
every single Instagram post it doesn't
make it know what once you register
yourself as an author yeah that I don't
think that type of protection exists
currently for YouTube please not forget
all the creativity on the net that is
not made for profit I mean of course it
is very important that people who want
to live from their creativity can do so
so that's not the question the question
is whether we want to enforce their
rights in a way that flattens out
everything else and that's what what's
happening right now this is one way to
do it I mean you say it's the best way
but there's other ways to get
remuneration to to creators without
having these huge collateral effects
that we're gonna see through this
directive and that's the critique really
Allen regardless of how the provisions
are implemented here isn't this Lama
certainly going to create more
bureaucracy at the moment there's no
bureaucracy right the that every law
creates an agency that enforces it and
creates controls and so on you can call
that bureaucracy but that's typical sort
of Silicon value Silicon value Valley
speak that's framing isn't it that's you
know European units trying to enforce
laws laws that already exist if you have
a copyright someone has to pay you for
using it so how to enforce that law
against these huge tech giants who which
are international that's what this is
about
and that's not bureaucracy of that the
main intent is the rule of law now would
this law possibly flatten normal craters
I don't know if I upload one of the
photo I've taken a bike at onto Facebook
and someone else uses it and I haven't
copyrighted in any way well that's fine
it's fine by me I love all sorts of
people to see my cat right and people
post cat jokes and so on
let that be but if someone wants to live
off a web site that posts cat jokes or
cat photos then have them register it's
you know call at bureaucracy I call
organizing to enforce your rights which
has been the bedrock of civil society
since the 18th century may I just ask
John to what degree the way that this
law is implemented is really already set
in stone certainly members of the German
government have been saying since
passage of the directive that it won't
uh sure e'en change as drastic as what
many people fear and the German justice
minister for example said she doesn't
like the idea of upload filters but
she's absolutely determined to implement
this law in such a way that it
quote-unquote does not disrupt freedom
of expression on the web so isn't there
more flexibility here than meets the eye
well I mean for a start we have to
assume the worst if a law is made and if
it's enforce then it's gonna take a
couple of years it's gonna take a
maximum of two years that's the rule no
but we we asked some some very
high-ranking German law professors
whether this law as it was now passed in
Brussels allows for what exists for
example the federal government has said
they want to do in Germany and they said
no on the basis of this text this softer
solution that the German government is
now proposing is not even possible under
European law because if you want to have
an exception to copyright that's a very
very strict regime in the EU it says you
need to have an exception anchor in the
European law and then you can do it on
on the national level and this anchor
doesn't exist in the text that's why up
until the last minute people said please
open up this article thirteen again
to make at least this possible and that
would lead to a kind of flat fee rule
that that creators would be paid through
collecting societies on a flat basis but
not on an individual basis and this
individual thing is what makes filtering
necessary and certainly this new
directive is provoking genuine and
heated opposition from young Europeans
in particular protests here in Berlin
the EU have brought thousands into the
streets these young people are upset
about the new legislation they say it
could lead to online censorship and
restrictions on freedom of speech the
Internet as we know it will cease to
exist
you won't be able to use the original
works of others to create something new
it'll smother creativity on the Internet
supporters of filter technology
including groups from the music
publishing and video industries say it
will help cut down on piracy the Hindu
quintus claimed the big platforms are
trying to protect their financial
interests they're trying to convince the
kids that this will ruin the Internet do
they claim that you won't be able to
have your own channels on YouTube
anymore
it couldn't well that's just for the
truth all this opposition has made some
politicians nervous because they're
worried about losing a lot of young
voters so how can we protect copyrighted
material on the Internet grace all this
talk about upload filters and censorship
machines and the big dangers for content
creators is it possible the tech giant's
themselves were behind some of these
arguments and even helped incite the
protests I think that it doesn't give
enough credit to the people of the
internet who see very fundamental
changes potentially being made because
this isn't just riling up people in
Europe this would potentially affect the
entire Internet as we know it which is a
scary prospect John as we heard there
some politicians have absolutely
downplayed the authenticity of the
protests they've said this is just a
tempest in a teapot as it were now I
looked it up this morning the average
age of EU parliamentarians is 54 years
is it possible that many of those who
voted for this directive simply don't
really get the Internet I think they
don't get the
the fears that people have because they
don't get the internet I think that's
like this that's a gap between the
generations yes I think so
so Alan regardless of who's right on the
merits is such a generation gap risky at
this point in time given that we have
just two months until some very critical
EU elections it's probably risky but I
think politicians need to explain to
people who are demonstrating that the
idea that you get something for free
it's wrong you don't there is no such
thing as a free lunch there is no such
thing as a free Internet it was a
beautiful idea I signed on to it 20
years ago myself I thought yeah that's
it but it's it's naive and it's
dangerous if the fact because we pay for
everything we know we pay for everything
that supposedly for free with our data
we also pay other people pay content
providers pay by getting ripped off
and the people who get this data and who
you and who make billions on ripping off
other people's content in Silicon Valley
and and and elsewhere and they are just
laughing at us so the fact that Europe
now says no sorry you know they're
nothing is free if you want free public
transport taxpayers pay it if you want
free health care tax payers pay it if
you want free Internet content providers
pay it and you pay it with your data and
the fact that there is no free lunch
this is something that politicians have
to explain to young people because
they're not used to it but it's a fact
of life but now young people are having
to explain to politicians how the
internet works and how sharing of
information and and by measure content
happens on the internet there's no way
to wall off any segments of the Internet
and not have it affect the entire
ecosystem I think there just remains a
fundamental misunderstanding from the
point of parliamentarians who voted for
this as to how the internet works also
the framing that that young people want
everything for free is is a very
dangerous one because they are not
against
creators being paid they are just
against the the means that are now
employed to do that and and politicians
just kind of went through it like this
and thinking all these young people
they're just shouting because they want
to get everything for free nothing is
for free and I guess the young people
know that but they just don't want to
get the Internet as we know are
destroyed on the just for the money be
destroyed you're you you represent
wikimedia Wikipedia is explicitly
exempted from all the things of the text
of it yes well the text okay you may
have a problem with the odd the odd
photograph I'm sure you'll get around
that I'm sure you'll be able to employ a
couple of people are gonna help you with
that explicitly also people should have
a young creative who makes a video in in
her in her living room using Beyonce's
backing track on some whatever she's not
going to be because the she has to have
two million viewers or so before it's
even sort of comes into the focus of the
upload filter and and this is not it
being explained to young people that
young boy we saw I think was a boy
saying that he wanted to use other
people's stuff to be creative he can no
one is stopping him and no one's telling
him that no one is stopping him that's
what you think is gonna happen in the
future but they young people people
obviously don't trust that the
politicians in Brussels that obviously
to a large extent don't don't understand
how the internet works that they make a
rule that works in that way it's a trust
problem I think and and the exact
execution of how these rules are going
to be enforced is completely unknown at
this point
the idea of an upload filter is what it
boils down to but when it comes down to
it the the very specific nuances of
copyright law are extremely extremely
complicated and there's absolutely a
justified fear that the small content
creators will get caught in the webs of
upload filters
I'd like to widen our focus just a
little bit in the last few minutes of
the program and I must say amongst the
young people I spoke to at this week's
protest after the directive was passed a
lot of anger was reserved not just for
politicians but also for the tech giants
does the new law leave their power
undiminished data from billions of
consumers is available on the Internet
and processing it has become a lucrative
industry last year Google's parent
company alphabet reported a total net
income of 30 billion dollars much of it
from advertising Google is able to
create personalized ads that target
people who might want to buy a product
that helps to boost advertising revenue
big internet corporations like Google
are part of the digital ecosystem but
critics say they have too much power and
can influence the behavior of consumers
and politicians do these corporations
pose a threat john the head of wikipedia
so not wikimedia but your cousin as it
were tweeted after the new directive was
passed that the new law quote is not
about helping artists it's about
empowering monopolistic practices would
you agree with that and would you say
that in the end the tech titans will be
laughing all the way to the bank
despite this new law well in on a
relative if you compare it to the
smaller ones I guess the Giants will
profit because they have the systems to
do what is now required by the law and
in that respect they will and in other
respects I guess they will get targeted
more with claims for compensation and
payment so it's it's a two-sided thing I
would say if we look at new digital
policy as a whole isn't Europe in fact
doing more to curb monopoly power and
practices on the internet than any other
region in the world at the moment
absolutely I mean take China for
instance they simply cut off the
internet for outside influences have
their own people like Alibaba and so on
to provide content that America almost
totally unregulated Europe is the
biggest market in the world and what
we're doing now is attempting without
data protection laws with a copyright
protection laws with upcoming monopoly
laws to do something about a
about monopolies whoo you can't get hold
of because they're not like steelworks
or oil works which oil companies which
sit somewhere and you can sort of grab
them they're everywhere are nowhere and
we're trying and I think it's great that
we're trying we may be making mistakes
I'm I'm you know I'm not don't Matt not
dogmatic but I think we're going in the
right direction grace the EU
commissioner who imposed record
antitrust fines an apple on Google
Margaret Vesta yeah
she described package of the new
directive quote unquote as great news
how do you square that with her strong
stance on antitrust and trying to
essentially rein in these giant
companies I think coming from the United
States where deregulation has been the
rule for the past for my entire lifetime
basically I never thought we would see
the day when some of these tech giant
start getting broken up I think that is
a path that's that we're going down
worldwide within the United States
that's even a discussion as to whether
these companies should be broken up and
will be broken up but I think the way
that the EU is trying to legislate the
internet amounts to a new kind of
colonialism honestly so even in the u.s.
grace has just said broken up even in
the US which of course is home to these
big tech titans John Woodsman there are
increasing calls now for the breakup of
these giant companies do you in fact
think that's the road we're going down
and if we look at the precedent of
Microsoft in 2000 would you say that was
an effective way to tame that giant well
if you look at the systems that the
European Union uses in their offices and
it's all Microsoft yeah I think it
didn't work well I think nobody contests
the fact that some of those titans as
you call them are just too big for any
market model to to work but but our
point is always to say don't use
copyright law to fix that use antitrust
law use competition law to do that and
that is what you you is also doing right
now but that's the the right tools and
and don't do it with copyright law
because that affects everybody
on the net sin sent and it came about so
that's the wrong tool Alan EU elections
two months from now what would you want
to see a new EU Commission and or a new
EU Parliament do in this area to bring
these huge tech companies under some
form of control go down the same road
we're going now which is not breaking
them up into smaller entities which will
then develop into bigger entities but
empower the citizen give you the right
to take your own data away from these
people take when you leave Facebook take
all your data away from Facebook take it
to somewhere else when you decide not to
use Google to have that taken away from
Google take whatever you want
what's already happened now the data
protection law to go further down that
path it's to so that you absolutely know
who's got what on me it's the individual
citizen not the state that needs to
control these tech giants and Europe is
helping us do that
grace very briefly if I go back to our
title cashing in on the net until now
that has been largely the prerogative of
these huge companies what do you think
will it change in future their business
models won't change no III don't think
so at all and I think that the idea that
this type of copyright law could then
somehow distribute that money to
individual content creators is dubious
at best John I agree with grace well
like I said I think Europe's doing a
good job let's let's hurray for Europe
right great last words thank you very
much to all of you for being with us and
thanks to you out there for tuning in
see you soon
[Music]
you